Since its founding in 1998, Rotten Tomatoes
has become the go-to site for getting a quick
idea of what film critics think of a movie.
Your individual tastes might vary and we all
love to watch some trashy cinema every now
and then but you can generally count on a
film with a high score to bring some quality
to the table.
If you really want the cream of the crop,
though, you can look for the films that racked
up a unanimous critical endorsement and scored
the coveted 100%.
But there’s a catch.
The scores and the professional reviews that
generated them stay up on Rotten Tomatoes
forever, and almost all of them were written
when the films were first released.
While many great movies can stand the test
of time, the years that pass can eventually
reveal some flaws.
Here are a few movies that haven’t aged
well, despite their 100% scores from the critics.
The Interview
If you're surprised that The Interview got
a 100 percent score, you're probably thinking
of the 2014 movie about James Franco and Seth
Rogen being sent to assassinate the leader
of North Korea.
“Take him out."
"You want us to kill the leader of North Korea?"
"Yes."
”Whaaaaaaaat?”
That movie has also aged badly, but it wasn't
exactly beloved to begin with.
This Interview is a 1998 Australian crime
drama starring Hugo Weaving that made a big
splash in indie film circles when it was released
in the United States in 2000.
The question is, why?
The film consists almost entirely of an interrogation
of Weaving's character at the hands of a police
detective.
It's like an Australian Usual Suspects, but
with worse writing and no budget for flashbacks.
Whether he's guilty or simply being railroaded
is kept from the audience to a degree that
makes it had to find any truth in the story
to latch onto.
If you want proof that Hugo Weaving is a very
good actor, The Interview will accomplish
that, but you can find that same proof in
a much more entertaining form elsewhere.
Roger & Me
In 1989, Roger & Me seemed charming.
The work of a then-unknown documentary filmmaker
named Michael Moore, it featured the story
of his troubled hometown of Flint, Michigan,
and Moore's quest to confront General Motors
CEO Roger B. Smith.
The film goes into detail about the harm the
company did to Flint by laying off huge numbers
of workers in favor of cheaper labor in other
countries, and Moore's dogged pursuit is engaging,
even though he never manages to meet with
his subject.
When it was released, this movie was nothing
like the impersonal documentaries that audiences
were used to.
Three decades later, though, it’s a lot
harder to enjoy.
Flint never recovered, and is still a city
in crisis today.
Michael Moore, meanwhile, is still doing his
best to present the same "dogged everyman"
persona that won over audiences in this film,
but it feels far less sincere coming from
an industry veteran than it did from an unknown
in his 30s.
In 1989, Michael Moore became a liberal hero,
but these days audiences think he's overstayed
his welcome, regardless of their politics,
if box office receipts are any indication.
In that sense, you could say that Moore's
own success has ruined his best film.
Longtime Companion
Longtime Companion was a movie that needed
to be made.
Its 1990 release was groundbreaking, presenting
audiences with the first widely distributed
motion picture dealing with the AIDS crisis
that had been decimating the gay community
for a decade.
Unfortunately for modern viewers, the sadness
of its story is far from the only thing that
makes it hard to watch.
Craig Lucas and Norman René, the writer and
director of the movie, were both gay men who
lived in the world they were depicting, but
some LGBTQ activists felt like they were playing
it safe in their depiction of the gay community.
These critics called the movie out for being
afraid to depict gay men as anything other
than affluent and white, and to depict their
relationships as truly romantic and sexual.
It’s clear that a major goal of the film
was to tell a story that needed to be told
to the people who hadn't heard (or lived)
it.
In that sense, Longtime Companion was a huge
success in its time, but nobody watches it
anymore, and there's a reason for that.
The Terminator
Oh, Terminator - you're one of our favorite
movies ever, but that doesn't mean you've
properly stood the test of time, despite how
cool your special effects were for 1984.
We're only a decade away from Kyle Reese's
cyborg-filled future, and we still have very
little of the technology that we saw.
Unfortunately, all the hairspray, neon-colored
clothes, and Sarah Connor's roommate's music
throughout Terminator often leaves us cringing
as to what things were like in the '80s.
The Terminator is justifiably looked back
on as a sci-fi-action classic, but from a
modern perspective, it has a few big things
working against it.
For starters, it’s a victim of its own success.
It’s so influential on everything that came
after that we've seen the innovations and
ideas that it brought to the screen refined
dozens of times over the years.
Even Arnold Schwarzenegger’s iconic emotionless,
unstoppable killing machine, which blew audiences
away in 1984 and made Arnold a household name,
seems a little less special after 30 years,
a handful of sequels, and a couple hundred
imitators.
“I’ll be back…"
"Ha!
Didn't think I was going to say that, did
you?"
"That's what you always say!”
“... I do?”
In that respect, it’s a lot like watching
the fight scenes in The Matrix and trying
to remember how innovative they were before
that style was in literally every action movie.
Secondly, there's Sarah Connor, the target
that the Terminator is sent back in time to
execute.
By Terminator 2: Judgment Day, we've seen
Linda Hamilton evolve into a muscular, battle-ready
action hero in her own right, which is the
main thing that makes revisiting the first
movie feel so off.
Here, she’s a nearly helpless, big-haired
damsel in distress who has to be rescued,
and the fact that she's being targeted solely
because she’s eventually going to be someone’s
mom isn’t the most empowering storyline
for a female science fiction lead.
“they came to fight…
For the one woman who could save their future.”
None of this ruins what is definitely still
a great movie, but for a film about the future,
it definitely feels dated.
The Searchers
John Ford's 1956 western The Searchers is
one of the most beautiful films ever made,
and features what is easily the best performance
by screen legend John Wayne.
Wayne stars as Ethan Edwards, a Civil War
veteran who spends years looking for his niece
after she's kidnapped by Native Americans,
leading him to hate all Comanches.
That hate is treated as a flaw in his character,
and that’s a far more nuanced and progressive
perspective than was common in westerns of
that era.
Unfortunately, that nuance just makes the
still-ingrained racism throughout the movie
all the more glaring.
There's a whole subplot with a Native American
woman who believes herself to be married to
a white man who has no interest in her, played
entirely for laughs.
Beyond that, Ethan's blatant racism particularly
when he expresses a willingness to kill his
own niece if she's slept with or even been
assaulted by a Native American makes him seem
less like a deeply flawed anti-hero and more
like a monster.
The Searchers is absolutely worth watching
for its cinematography and performances, but
there’s a lot you’ll have to ignore to
enjoy it.
Holiday Inn
Racism has to be pretty egregious to stand
out in a movie from 1942, but Holiday Inn
manages to pull it off in a single scene.
If you've ever seen it, or even just watched
the trailer, you've already know exactly what
we’re talking about..
The premise of the Bing Crosby/Fred Astaire
musical revolves around a resort that's only
open on holidays, with each holiday having
its own song and dance number.
It famously gave the world "White Christmas,"
which would go on to become Crosby’s signature
song and the best-selling single of all time,
but not every holiday was so lucky.
Abraham Lincoln's birthday is celebrated with
a number in which the white performers are
dressed as black stereotypes, complete with
the exaggerated blackface makeup that was
common in racist 19th century minstrel shows.
The entire sequence has been cut from TV airings
of the film, but today, most people watch
it on DVD or streaming, where it's still there.
There's a lot to like in Holiday Inn, and
a lot of great music and dancing, but this
shocking relic that was past its time even
in the ‘40s is enough to ruin the whole
thing.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!